what's going on guys this is Laura King
David now usually we do these things in
the movie theater right after I didn't
have my setup I didn't have anything
ready to go I went with Lord MJ the boss
and I went with Lord o supreme to go see
Dark Phoenix and um what I'm saying is
I'm a video comic-book purist alright so
when I go to a lot of these movies and I
see a lot of these things I understand
that um oh you're trying to figure out
this setup oh we in the California
compound right this is e to me no
jewelry on you just get straight rollin
I'll cut right this is it right
so um Arnall with the lord is here so
watching the film now i must preface
this with I'm a purist from the comic
books right and I never felt that the
Fox films for x-men lived up to what it
was I think to be honest with you we
were going through a transitional period
where they didn't understand that comic
books can be exactly what we read right
but out of all the the movies two books
the x-men always stayed really you know
grounded in comic book lore they did
change a couple of suits and they had to
work with the scripts that they have
like Kevin Feige does with the Avengers
right so you know they're not able to
use certain things we don't know what's
what's given to them all right remember
in the comic books they are able to do
and and say pretty much anything that
they want to say and do right so get
into this movie
spoiler alert let me let you know right
now I'm going to give you spoilers okay
now um don't don't stick to the end this
is not a traditional Marvel film in
which you're gonna stick to the end
you're gonna see some end credits that
has anything to do with stuff is a lot
of rumors online talking about Dark
Phoenix will show you something and
Captain Marvel
crap ton of crap um if it was something
I really didn't see it and if they
trying to say that some of the
protagonists in this film
I mean antagonist in this film
represented something that was from
Captain Marvel that was a lie all right
this is a whole different thing
all right so yes this is round table
reviews with the Lords drinks is in
session okay so let me give you my take
on that universe first before I delve
into this movie
now I thought the universe was kind of
messed up when it had everything to do
that they broke the continuity of the of
the universe all right so I'm gonna view
this as not a continuum book not on a
miniseries I'm gonna give this as a one
shot you ever get one of those one-shot
comic books that was really fantastic
and you said man this is this is great
it was a one shot and it felt like the
writers gave it a hundred percent
they're all and it felt like you know
the artwork was on point home so there's
a lot of one shot or king-sized books
that you purchased back in the days that
encapsulates exactly what I'm gonna talk
about here all right so we know that
that universe is done this was their
last film right
I thought the universe was it reached
its peak with avengers first class i
thought that was a master class of a
movie I thought it introduced characters
I thought it gave characters good
grounding I thought it allowed you to
see things in that universe and made you
feel for these characters right and you
saw things and it expressed stuff to you
that you said wow I didn't understand
that I see the universe that they
building and then they follow that up
with
a week rendition of apocalypse alright
so those people that are in fear of this
film being a regurgitated scenario of
Age of Apocalypse don't fear
okay first and foremost I must say that
this movie is well done
every character matured into their
essence you know they be cast well the
casting is spot-on in this film and you
have to understand they did this casting
when he started this universe okay now
in the books the Dark Phoenix the book
which is one of the greatest reads it's
up there with Infinity Gauntlet now for
the x-men besides House of M this book
the Dark Phoenix saga is actually one of
those books that is a must read and the
reason why is a must read is because
this is a pivotal point in the x-men
history that makes you say wow I'm
really part of you know something
special
okay now digging deep into this movie
and watching it on the screen I'm going
to give you the comic book and then I'm
going to give you as a film the comic
book version of this movie this movie
tries to touch upon it the charge a
touch upon the the Shannara
and their lore the Shannara is a race
and has a high queen and she's in love
with Professor Xavier he actually has a
love affair with her and it's off world
and they do stuff and the x-men has to
battle the Shema guard and gladiator
which is the first gladiator is the
first version of Superman
that we've received in a Marvel Universe
okay actually as a custom is designed
like Superman I has a mohawk him he's
really good that's he's a very good
character and that's also with Woodring
got his his brown and what is it orange
suit because before that it was the
yellow and blue right so he got into a
fight and his suit got tattered and the
guy that he killed
he took his suit so in this movie we
know there is no Wolverine they replaced
Wolverine with the Beast and I think
working with what you have is part of
being creative right so this is a
one-shot deal
in watching this movie with the
resources they have at hand they
perfected their universe if this is that
last shot if this was the way it was
going out I know they looked at as we've
been brought out this is it and we have
to give everything any did they left
nothing on the floor this is how you
want your chance to go out you want them
to go out standing up you want them to
be counted out if they're gonna get
knocked out you want your chance to rise
from his from his feet and if he gets
knocked down because the Age of
Apocalypse was a knock down they got up
there answered the call and they decided
to did the level and this movie delivers
in spades if you are x-men fan this
movie shows you why you're a fan magneto
is Magneto Professor Xavier is perfect
Xavier storm is storm Nightcrawler
actually becomes the badass we always
expected him and wanted him to be
Quicksilver is who he's supposed to be
and the dark feelings is omnipotent you
understand this unapproachable
she is it definitely and what the books
call for and I love this this is like a
what-if book what if this happened and
they used everything in their resources
to give you great cinema I walked out of
that movie thoroughly pleased wanting to
see it again because I felt that this
stands alongside of x-men's first class
and I thought x-men first class can
stand us stand alongside any MCU
universe movie this movie is completely
different from what you would expect
because I went in there with absolute
hate in my blood ready to condemn this
movie from top to bottom but from the
protagonist which is Jean Grey and she
takes in the Phoenix force they never
give it a name you know they didn't name
the the Shannara because the Shannara is
not shapeshifters you know they're just
a race of being that's above the you
know human form but I understand they
wanted to be ambiguous and they never
gave a name to the race you know if I
wanted to critique some things but maybe
they couldn't maybe they didn't you know
they weren't able to and they had powers
that shemagh doesn't have but they had
to give you a threat level that was on
par to face the Phoenix because the
Phoenix force is honestly one of the
beginning forces in the universe that
can challenge the Infinity Gauntlet and
pure raw power you know there is some
forces that's in the Marvel Universe and
this is one of those forces that is
definitely 100% on par with the Infinity
Gauntlet they gave you a masterclass of
a movie
they gave you scenes where you felt for
characters that died
yes characters do die here now that's
one spoiler I won't spoil for you I do
encourage you to go see the film because
when this character dies you're not
gonna expect it and it's gonna come
right out of the blue it's gonna hit you
in the gut because this is exactly how a
character is supposed to act this is how
Magneto's supposed to act when he built
his compound for his wayward mutants his
acolytes these are things that you read
these books and we have matured we are
in control now we're gonna give you the
best of what our law has rich content
that keeps you in boost this movie it's
a king's thumbs up and I truly expect
people to go out and support this movie
see it and understand where I'm coming
from go in there cynical because I went
in cynical from the door 100% in my
heart I went in there ready to condemn
this film but the film actually lived up
to way better than I can ever deem it to
be when you can make Professor Xavier an
alcoholic spoiler alert an alcoholic
Professor Xavier dipping into the bottle
and I noticed it early on you have
definitely reached a point in film in
cinema where they were laying it all out
so shout out to Fox on your last joint
going out I know New Mutants is supposed
to be on deck I don't know what happens
with that I thought this film was going
to be
wiped off the slates so shout out to
bloody knuckles for telling me it wasn't
and they didn't hope he went in
slaughters film but this film was
definitely a way to start off III my
other Lords they couldn't make it
through it too tight but I'm I went out
there and I do I do think that this
roundtable review it's what's necessary
please go out please support hey guys
don't forget like follow and subscribe
you know the rules
shout out to everybody that's watching
us also go to Lords of gaming net where
this review will be up you can go see
Kos king of the statues combat talk with
the king which I'll be doing later on
today with Gennady golovkin and roles
also Lord the last word or loyal kognito
and Evon says for that looter shooter
news destiny just talked about a new dlc
that is about to hit these streets with
a hell of a lot of content so and they
expressed that there's no more
playstation treatment and peripheral
treatment that changed so i'm excited
for the last word being able to bring
all this content to you take care guys
see you at the next move your view
hopefully i'm there with the lords but
uh lord king is here catch you guys
later
[Music]